est-ce que vous pouvez s'il vous plaît
vous taire et écouter la première
ministre vous ne latéraux vous ne cessez
de l'interrompre monsieur Boyard
monsieur Boyard je vous demande de vous
taire
monsieur brouillard monsieur Boyard je
vous rappelle alors
je prononce à votre rencontre un appel à
l'endroit avec inscription au
procès-verbal
je vous prie de vous taire et de
respecter cette assemblée la première
ministre
[Applaudissements]
avoir un problème c'est sûr quand est-ce
que ce mec sort de l'Assemblée au bout
d'un moment c'est insupportable il est
tout le temps il est tout le temps
agressif
comme ça avec la présidente de
l'Assemblée avec pouvoir sortir les mecs
et avec ou sans alcool même quand il
boit pas il est agressif c'est toujours
pareil
quand on
est content
mais quand on conduit on a pas le droit
d'être alcoolisé et on a pas le droit
d'être sous empreintes de cannabis moi
je vois pas pourquoi l'Assemblée
nationale
il devrait tester s'il y a vraiment une
ambiguïté devrait tester voir s'ils sont
sous emprise soit de stupéfiant soit
d'alcool et de comprendre
c'est comme ça dans les entreprises les
amis je vous le dis dans les autres
entreprises arrivé ça arrive le travail
éméché il y a quelqu'un qui va dire hop
le chef la DRH si je te jure que c'est
vrai
que vous qui est dans votre monde ils
ont le droit d'avoir des voitures ils
ont droit de paper les restaurants 8000
€, il les mérite ils sont bourra les
sembler et à l'Assemblée il les mérite
il y a que vous il y a que vous pour
dire ça non mais quand j'entends ici que
je vous dis des trucs vous me dites non
c'est normal il mérite leur salaire il
mérite leur voiture ils méritent tout
mais tu vas ils sont pas dans la vraie
vie ils sont pas dans le vrai monde
arrive au boulot
au boulot
parce qu'il continue à investir la
première ministre et la présidente quand
elle lui dit ce sera inscrit au
procès-verbal c'est un quart de son
indemnité parlementaire qui saute
pendant un mois et d'ailleurs ça
commence à le faire taire ah oui ça fait
à peu près 2000 € de sanctions
financière parce que c'est 7005 un peu
moins de 2000 €, il est juste énervé et
pas bon
arrête moi c'est ça aussi tu as raison
c'est la c'est les potes de Gilles
Verdez non c'est pas mes potes c'est pas
mes amis c'est pas mes amis
c'est pas mes amis c'est pas mes amis un
peu tes amis c'est quoi le dire c'est
pas mes amis c'est pas mes amis c'est
pas mes amis mais c'est plus tes amis
que Marine Le Pen c'est pas mes amis
j'en ai pas mes amis c'est bon quoi
c'est pas mes amis c'est que mes amis je
vais terminer un peu le droit eh
cherchez pas ils ont tous les droits
allez on embrasse tes amis
c'est pas mes amis
ils ont tous les droits à chercher par
retour à l'essence passez-moi pour un
démago passez moi pour un fou à
Guillaume passez-moi pour info ils ont
tous les droits arriver sur lieu de
travail
faut mettre tous les députés est-ce que
j'ai mis tous les députés
nationale les hommes politiques ils ont
tous les droits je suis désolé c'est
comme ça ils étaient pas vaccinés ils
rentraient quand même oublie jamais ça
les amis
tu pouvais rentrer à l'Assemblée c'était
pas vacciné ils ont jamais eu de passe
sanitaire ils ont ils sont rentrés à
l'Assemblée je suis sûr mais certain ils
sont rentrés à l'Assemblée sans passe
sanitaire ah bah les mecs ont pensé
téléspectateurs
ah bah il y a pas beaucoup d'amis de
ville euh oui il y a 75% non à 24%
voyons pas il y en a 24 % sont pas
choqués vous qui était choqués là qui
sont pas choqués
lapin qui est pas choqués ah ouais toi
tu es pas choqué
que par lui même les autres les mêmes
les autres députés qui gueule comme ça
le spectacle qui montre de l'Assemblée
où ils dorment où il s'engueule avec les
gens ils vont les mettre à chaque fois
je m'endors
c'est sain et c'est bien que également
c'est le lieu c'est le lieu justement où
il représente le citoyen donc c'est
normal que ça soit même que ça
frictionne et que ça soit mais il faut
qu'il s'écoute voilà là il s'écoute pas
là il fait que bugler donc voilà mais
c'est pas normal que sa gueule plus à
l'Assemblée nationale que sur un plateau
télé sa gueule plus que sur le plateau
de TPMP l'Assemblée nationale il y a
plus d'insultes plus d'indictives et les
nups ils font tous la même chose ils
aboient ils hurlent pour qu'on les
écoute mais ça marche pas du tout et
d'ailleurs ils sont en train c'est pas
ça va pas en ce moment mais franchement
il a dit que ça pourrait se dissoudre
s'ils arrivent pas se mettre d'accord
donc c'est pas une bonne stratégie ça
fonctionne sans respecter on se respecte
un petit peu on a une attitude
respectable donc voilà pour les Boyard
petit message personnel à Louis Boyard
non mais c'est vrai regardez-moi ça
mais non mais quand tu es vénère
non voilà faut pas pousser mémé dans les
orties hein
non mais j'ai quel est son bilan à Louis
donc on se souviendra de quoi il a
déclaré qu'il se mettrait jamais de
cravate super programme ça va aider les
gens il a il a pas voulu serrer la main
personne de rassemblement national un
député un collègue voilà son programme
et c'est plus grave et quand il parle en
plus au nom de la jeunesse
il représente pas toute la jeunesse il
faut quand même le préciser parce que il
parle souvent
et sa dernière proposition de loi c'est
d'interdire le l'interdiction du partage
de compte Netflix je pense qu'il devait
être bourré quand il a écrit parce que
c'est son urgence interdire
l'interdiction de partage de compte fixe
ça c'est proposition
la grève dans toutes les facs et tout ça
n'a pas marché
de filmer qu'on bloque
les pauvres lui il y a une sanction
électorale il y a des élections
allez pauvre Louis